ya know when to welcome to this video
playing Grand Master ultra mate in rock
on ok so what does he do here going for
the Roxy binds no he isn't it looks a
bit silly somehow against the three but
it's probably play off so I can focus
should be three okay preventing that ok
let's go h6 learn how to see organized
his play here probably for before
cooling
I can I can try to do basically the same
thing a 6b five myself not sure about it
if this is a good idea I don't see a
real issue with this okay so i have to
trade this I think will be liable will
be a liability on f5 long term and then
just neither six and castles probably it
takes it edit an interesting decision
yeah but it is a bit loose area this is
whole thing 97 it's not an issue really
i think let's do this 97 King g7 that's
pretty okay I did not think about this
move at all huh
I wonder if I have some funny funny
ideas here with taking here Andrew age 7
and then some g5 it looks extremely
strange way I think it is interesting
and I let's try it might might be
completely completely terrible but it
can be interesting this bishop moves and
then g5 yeah it was not all that works I
wouldn't be surprised if it is
completely complete rubbish but kind of
interesting i also have night f4 and 93
ideas on
he always has Quincy to want it will
detect my c6 night yeah I gotta drive
that's right
yeah my deaf one
9f father maybe doesn't maybe it doesn't
work quite quite come quite full eight
and under noon he has g7 is the thing g7
under control this is probably the the
issue here sighs or something I maybe
just this I asking edge one also yes i
Luke g8 King edge one yeah now it
doesn't quite work near destruction
unfortunate and that what it was
interesting but yeah it doesn't doesn't
quite add up time morning okay still
Esther is still has to convert it I
Lucas really in bad shape but then i can
try this rookie one okay
it doesn't have that many porns so so
let's um slide hope that I can get rid
of most pause here a 95 it simplifies
okay okay okay okay first ethical
management realize okay so it doesn't
work it didn't work I mean I felt that
this was interesting but probably just
not quite there might be 6f to go now
[Music]
now I was just a little bit a little bit
too creative for its own good Queen f3
and assistive handsome okay so i should
have just fly something normal in fact
the engines to likes f5 in this position
it's weird and so we move the engine
move here he played the c forum it's a
very strange position i'd never would've
and of clay dad and five yeah i mean
okay there the whole thing I've kind of
pointed to analysis as I have the engine
on and this is like me playing he him
playing against the computer so it's
kind of pointless um I probably should
have done something I do a little
simpler
just uh yeah some something simple let's
say the engine likes that actually
that's it's funny I can probably just
play playing on the move and and be
somewhat shy okay that is that is
slightly worse yeah this is this kind of
thing yeah it's like it was that 95 our
bishops III was was certainly
interesting oh the engine shows this
idea where my development isn't great
that's very good for him here g5 okay
hit him and somehow felt there should be
some possibilities with this but I
didn't didn't put it into motion yeah
well then hold approaches for me wrong
he is a purely tactical player so not
the not the right way probably to play
against ok guys thanks for watching